hi i'm lior
and i want to talk to you today about
robust quantum entanglement
at nearly room temperature
okay so let's recall schroedinger's cat
so we've all heard about this uh
near-death experience of a thought
experiment feline
the way it's usually stated as you have
a cat which is entangled to a poison
vial
in the sense that um if the poison file
is unbroken the cat lives and if the
poison pile is broken the cat is not so
fortunate
so this is a textbook example on how to
explain entanglement
but actually it is a cynical view of
entanglement but this is schredinger's
way
of telling us that we're likely to see
or encounter
large macroscopic scale entanglements as
much as you can can entangle a cat to a
poison vial
but the question is is this cynicism
true
so when in doubt we blame the coherence
right we blame the coherence for
everything
um so what is the coherence you start
with a nice clean pure state
that you want to use say initialize and
say for short algorithm
and then you cover it to a heat bath
it's an auxiliary system
to which you have no access to this is
the world outside right
and then you let it thermalize and reach
some equilibrium
and the coherence is what it causes uh
it causes uncontrolled femalization
and it's usually cited as the root cause
that we are still not selling uh
quantum computers by the dozens
okay so now if we compare theory to real
life
ideally we'd like to manipulate pure
states on many qubits
but in reality we're unable to do so so
we're unable to
retain purity as the number of qubits
grows and the temperature increases
so we only get mixed states so
physically
in fact it's actually just kind of one
relevant mixed state it's the thermal
state it's e to the minus beta h over c
where um beta is called the inverse
temperature is one over
kappa t where t is temperature and kappa
is the bottom constant
and here h is some hamiltonian of your
choice
in other words this is a distribution
you can think of this as a distribution
on eigenstates
where each eigenstate is sampled with
probability
which is e to the minus uh it's it's
eigenvalue times theta
okay so let's go back to our previous
question
can we see entanglement at room
temperature well now the question in
this form should be
can you design a local hamiltonian
h such that its thermal state to the
minus beta h is entangled
so this would be corresponding to say
having a cat entangled to something like
microscopic scales so how can we test
for something being entangled if it's a
mixed state well it's hard to quantify
even for pure states
so instead we use here a proxy which is
quantum circuit lower balance
so here's a local quantum circuit it is
a product of
um d such unitaries one two up to d
and each layer is a tensor product of uh
say two local unitaries acting on pairs
of qubits
and you have these layers maybe working
on on different subsets of pairs
and you have these such layers and now
you can define circuit complexity
circuit complexity of state row is the
minimal integer d
for which there exists a such a unitary
circuit you that if it acts on the
all zero state which is completely
unentangled and then you may be tossing
away some of the qubits
you can approach your target state to
some uh vanishing point systems
so for any state row we have a circuit
complexity
uh which is some integer so now our main
conjecture
using these notations is called robust
topological order at room temperature
we ask whether there exists a log of
hamiltonian h of n qubits
that is both topologically ordered in
other words it
it has a highly entangled ground state
and even for
some beta which is o of one uh the
thermal state has high circuit
complexity in other words
the syringe complexity of e to the minus
beta h is omega log n
the function here is somewhat important
because it somehow requires
or allows you potentially to couple any
pairs of qubits in your system
um so truth be told
if you look at this conjecture we know
of many local hamiltonians with a highly
tangled ground stick right these are
for example quantum error correcting
codes with large distance statutory code
but yet we don't know if any such
hamiltonian for which the thermal state
at high temperatures retains its circuit
lower bound
in other words for all we know the
quantum air correcting codes the good
ones that we know of
if you raise their temperature the
hamiltonian by a little bit
you may get something which is
completely decompered as a thermal state
in other words you may be able to
simulate
this quantum state to arbitrary
precision using very shallow circuits
the conjecture asks whether you can
somehow prevent them
and our main theorem is um that this
conjecture
holds for nearly optimal parameters in
other words there exists
a local hamiltonian nation in qubits
that is simultaneously
topologically ordered and for beta which
is maybe not over one but
of log log n right in other words the
temperature
is almost constant just decays like one
of the log log n uh the thermal state is
high
circuit complexity as desired as the
desired asset
so in fact we show our war we show that
the thermal state of these hamiltonians
is locally decodable to a highly
entangled
quantum state so in other words the
circuit logo that we
cite here uh actually emanates from
entanglement right so
circuit complexity is a proxy for
correlation not for entanglement it
could be the case that
you know hand waving here uh circuit uh
complexity lower bound but it could be
coming from uh classical correlations
classical long-range correlations
but in fact we showed that the circular
lines here
are actually coming from quantum from
proper quantum entanglement
so the take-home message if you just
want to quit the talk right now
is that um while we still can suddenly
go cat poison entangled state
um if we allow the hamiltonians to be
local
but not uh especially local so to allow
these
baroque mathematical constructions we
can get quantum systems that are
um on one hand truly quantum at zero
temperature they are topologically
ordered
and yet the entanglement persists at
very high temperatures
uh decaying only very gradually with
system size
okay so let's think about this for a
second how to entangle
things robustly so let's recap
our high level goal is as follows we try
to formulate
a local hamiltonian that has a highly
entangled ground state
and we want its thermal state at
temperature t
to be assigned circuit load balance for
all
sufficiently small t
and we'll show something stronger that
the thermal states are in fact highly
entangled it's not just a circuit low
down
so here's the main idea
so we can get quantum circuit load
balance for free
kind of for free from quantum air
correcting codes and this is kind of a
folklore result
that essentially uses the fact that any
two orthogonal code states are
uh undistinguishable by any local
measurement this kind of implies
that for sufficiently small error you
can't do this for any
shallow circuit uh and we want to make
these low balance stick for high
temperatures
now this is non-trivial so we want to so
the way we do this we demonstrate
a shallow no depth decoder from the
thermal state to the ground in other
words
for any sufficiently small temperature
you consider the thermal state and you
show
that by applying a shadow recorder you
can get back to the ground state of the
hamiltonian
and then you can conclude the circuit
lower bound survives uh for the thermal
state simply by subtracting the depth of
the shadow decoder
so in other words uh the entire focus of
this talk
would be to demonstrate a shadow decoder
from state to the ground
state and this would kind of conclude
the proof
so here's the main problem to do this um
thermostat is defined in terms of
energies right it's a distribution
corresponding to viable energy however
once you talk about consider local
decoding essentially you need
to know something about errors so how
can we translate from one region
which is physically motivated to another
regime where
we have all the technology for air
correction
so we need to change regimes so let's
talk about
uh the thermostat again so
for sufficiently small t if you plug
down the energies kind of schematically
with high eigenstates here and low
energies here
you can think that for sufficiently
small t most of them are concentrated on
the cool side maybe
there is some tail going into the high
energy states
and then you can talk about the regime
of errors you can think about regimes
of areas where there's a large distance
large weight errors and places where the
air is small weight
okay so essentially uh our your
kind of desire would be to have this map
between high energy states and highway
errors and low interest states and low
weight errors
and the way to do this in fact i think
the only way to do this would be to use
kind of quantum locally testable codes
that do this kind of by definition so
i'm not going to cite here the formal
definition
but essentially quantum locally testable
codes are generalization of
classical ltcs uh in the way that
they penalize uh any error uh
according to its uh hemi weight or
distance
from the code space
okay but um unfortunately this is still
not enough
right uh even if you can use leverage
quantum local testability
uh to force the errors to have low
weight
they could potentially form large
clusters
and this happens because um the regime
of temperatures that we consider here
the beta
um the temperature is pretty high in
other words you can
for teas we consider you can get
clusters of size n over log log n
this is like way beyond your air
correction capability
and you may in that situation you may
not be able to do even shallow decoding
so we need something more we need the
airway to be actually
uh very very sparse i mean like one
hairs to kind of
break away to these small clusters
because
in that regime you can actually hope to
have a shallow decoding skin
so so now we can't uh kind of kick the
can any longer we somehow need to
tackle this problem head-on so now we
consider the thermal states and we want
to analyze it in terms of errors
um and the way we do this is we
redefine the thermal state as a random
process uh it's called the metropolis
hastings algorithm
and it formulates this is a random error
model e
where an error e occurs with probability
that it's coverable
to the additional penalty it produces
and then what you can show that if you
let a system
kind of reach its equilibrium under a
local hamiltonian
which is derived from a quantum ltc
with quantum soundness then its
stationary distribution
has typically small clusters so formally
we say this
um if c is a quantum ltc with constant
soundness
and rho is a thermal mixed state and
under this e to the minus beta h of c
then if you look at a typical error
then its maximal connected component
is logarithmic in other words for
sufficiently small team which is one of
the logo again
uh you can the quantum local testability
property forces the errors
to be very very uh well spread out
and this is a crucial component
so now let's recall again the required
ingredients so we need a quantum error
correcting code
to kind of gain the full core result
of circuit load balance at the zero
temperature
we want the code to be a quantum ltc
with constant soundness and now the
final component is that
we want to be able to locally correct
sparse errors right we said that qrtc
brings us to the right regime
and now we want to be able to invoke
a shallow decoder to get the job done to
get us back to a code state
from the thermal state say by applying
some quantum variant of the
service speed but decoder so sufficient
condition for this
is that the tenor graph of the qltc
is locally expanding in other words if
you look at small subset of qubits s
then the number of check terms incident
on these
uh subsets is almost uh optimal it's
almost s times the degree
the maximum cubic
okay so this was the ingredients now
let's talk about the recipe
so um let's bring this to an actual
recipe so we start
with the best quantum ltc to date it's
called the projective code by literally
a lone and zemor and it's actually at
this conference it's a paper
and then we amplify it to constant
soundness
this by just taking random family of
subsets of check terms
and then we consider it's topology for
small subsets
and in fact we show that it is locally
expanding for small sets
how small uh as small as as large as we
need right so
we only care about subsets of site log n
and then we show that for
for such size which is very very small
um the expansion is very very good we
get here something which is like 1 over
16 in other words
um you locally expand almost like a tree
okay in other words um we're interested
we're interested only they're a gene
where s is very very small
typically if you talk about the six or
stream decoder you would be interested
in uh
side sets s of size which is linear in n
but here we are always in logarithmic
size
okay so to summarize
we've shown that quantum thermostats
governed by
a hamiltonian which is qltc uh have
for sufficiently small temperature
sparse errors
okay now in addition if these codes are
locally expanding in the sense that
we've just said in terms of the tanner
graph it means that we can
kind of correct these errors using
shallow circuits
and get back to the ground state where
we can claim
our large circuit load bound so this
means that the thermal state itself
for such hamiltonians is highly
entangled in a well-defined way
okay that was a technical summary so in
conclusion we can say that
macroscale entanglement can persist at
nearly room temperature
so maybe it's kind of a final statement
you can say schrodinger's cat is
possible
but maybe perhaps under a new name
perhaps reading this projective cat
which i drew it right here
thank you